[Music]
always remember the universe has a way
of leading you to where you're supposed
to be at the moment you're supposed to
be there let's do this
it took me 20 years to find you
people can say that
you are the best-kept secret in the
universe and I found you
which makes me perfect for this job you
really think a black suit is going to
solve all your problems
no but it's damn good on you we
[Music]
recognizable only as DejaVu and
dismissed just as quickly trying to
prove yourself agent M we may have a
problem in London welcome to mi beam you
will be with agent peach one of the best
ever to weather suit
[Music]
catching up on my daily meditation time
for lunch oh thank you hungry it's 9:30
Tuesday's taco day we've been
compromised puts every citizen of this
planet at risk
[Music]
[Applause]
you could all just look right here just
try
any fun left fun with it
there should be a big red button around
here somewhere found it we are the men
in black
looks like a tales of time
[Music]
you